hello good morning my name is Adam Smith
calling from nobelprize.org the website
of the Nobel Prize in Stockholm first of
all congratulations on the award of this
year's Nobel Prize thank you it could
hardly have come any quicker the
announcement was just last year
Einstein himself probably didn't think
that gravitational waves could be
recorded but you have always been a
believer I gather well I have been a
believer but I began I'm questioning my
gender is Einstein and by the time I
came along
there were lasers there were active
computers technology it changed and our
understanding of possible sources of
gravitational waves had changed neutron
stars and black holes it should be the
strongest sources Einstein had none of
that to base his ideas on so yes in his
seminal paper on gravitational waves he
indicated a skepticism gravitational
waves was never being ejected and now
they open a new window on the universe
what will we be able to see now that we
can detect gravitational waves I think
over the coming decades we will see
enormous numbers of things just as
electromagnetic astronomy was begun in
essence modern astronomy by Galileo
bugginess
telescope in this time discovering
Jupiter's moons this is the same thing
but for gravitational waves this is some
case the waves are the only other kind
of waves
besides electromagnetic sand propagate
across the universe bringing us
information about the universe so
initially we will see not just binary
black holes you'll see neutron stars
collide carry each other apart with you
black holes tear neutron stars apart we
will see spinning neutron stars pulsars
when the space station Lisa mission is
operating hopefully by about 2030
exploring basically in the birth of the
universe the earliest moments of the
universe and there will be ever so much
more I'm sure including huge surprise
talking a surprise is the one that
you've just received how did the news
come to you well I think it was not
unexpected opening I was hoping that the
prize would go to the lack of work on
collaboration or which made the
discovery or to the Leica laboratory the
scientists of the laws of laboratories
and designed and built and perfected the
gravitational wave detectors enough to
very wisely
we live in an era where some huge
discoveries are really the result of
giant collaborations with major
contributions coming from very large
numbers of people and I hope that in the
future Nobel Prize Committee finds a way
to award the prize to the large
collaboration that I guess is it is a
conversation and a debate that is going
to run and run yes it's nicely said so
will we be welcoming you to Stockholm in
December then once again congratulations
that we greatly look forward to meeting
you in December thank you